we were at the hospital to visit Bobby's
dad and his mom was changing the dad's
g-tube which was in a stomach so she had
to lift his hospital gown up and what
were your observations about your dad
baby if you're gonna say that my dad is
a bigger dick than me right now I can't
even [ __ ] believe bring up my dad
sick and that you're saying that my dad
is big I did it you said that my dad
definitely does but what I'm saying is
you said it first and I just agreed oh
you said that like mom like that is a
bigger dick than me and you kept looking
at it and so I obviously it was right in
front of my face I looked and yes he
does
by a lot jesus kalila you see man what
the [ __ ] relax lady it's so much bigger
than his day all right but I wasn't like
trying to perv out I'm just like me you
know I just agreed we got a bigger dick
than me all right and it's not his shaft
it's not as hairy as yours baby if you
stop talking about my dad there's that
dick oh my dad's dick you let me see
this no can I just say this in my family
I'm second cuz my brother's dick is
smaller than mine there you go
so Stevie's like this bra I'm not saying
you have a small dick I'm just saying
your dad's is bigger okay okay hey I
never said you had a small dick okay my
dad's a bigger dick yeah that's all I'm
saying
next time my dad is um undressing or
whatever to look at my dad's day um I
actually can you not let go if your mom
was sick and she was pulling up I would
not look at your mom's badge interesting
I go while you're your mom's vag is
tighter than your vag well that if I
said that your mom's vag is
Pinker and tighter like a little baby's
[ __ ] vagina number one I didn't say
it I merely agreed with you yeah you
said it first and I just nodded and said
yeah you're right you're right that's
all I said
yeah angry I'm not angry my dad is a
bigger dick he
SiC and that's that he's got bruises all
over his body it's like really hard to
see him that way you know it really is
difficult to see it's somebody that you
were so frightened of growing up you
know he was a guy that we just fear you
know and he is a shell of a man he's old
now he's extremely emotional like
because when you went down with my mom I
was just meeting my dad in my hotel in
the hotel room in the room and my dad
started crying he just cries I mean you
know I mean it's like you know you know
and it's really just really sad you know
and it's an unavoidable part of life and
when you're in it it's like I don't know
I mean it's not sad I guess it's you you
you just think to yourself wow this is a
part of life but I just never knew you
know as a kid you never think that
you're ever gonna be in this position to
take care of your folks you know but
here we are they always seemed
invincible your parents will always seem
like they cannot mm-hmm get sick they
can't falter but they'll always be just
these strong pillars in your life but
that's just not the case
um I wanted to point out something that
really frustrated me in the hospital and
you know we talked about this is you
know his parents don't his mom speaks
English perfectly to me she speaks
perfect English but you know there is an
accent barrier there so obviously when
when people are talking to her in
English too fast she's not going to
understand it his dad isn't able to
articulate sentences very well but it's
the way they were treated by the doctor
and it isn't like they didn't bring my
dad breakfast before I yeah he has like
blood sugar issues yeah and my mom got
they don't respond to the doctors come
in they don't say hi they don't talk and
you know I mean and they treat my
parents what if my brother and I aren't
there well my brother's there they get
[ __ ] done because my brother looks like
he's gonna kill them yeah yeah I mean so
when I walked in with kalila my mom's
complained like they don't either
treating us like immigrants right so
then Carla kalila presses the button the
nurse comes in and she'd look
she was scared because she sees both of
us you know I mean and then I tried him
and this is gonna sound really gross but
this is what I try to do always is I'll
do a little walk around just so that
anyone recognizes me because I think
that it works yeah
I think I really do if they say
something right now if you were a nurse
right and there was this old white man
right complaining my pelvis or whatever
my pelvis is burning and you're like I
don't want to [ __ ] help in white
man's below this so you don't go in
there right but then like decay you
realize it's Leo DiCaprio comes in
that's his dad would you be more
attentive of course would you really
yeah then you're a [ __ ] up nurse
because you should know you're not a
[ __ ] up nurse I think that's the way
the world works so that's that I don't
see it that way
I would treat anybody and I should every
nurse whoever it takes if you're in
health care you should just know you
good you should treat everybody you're
saying general would someone else no I
said you and that's it don't go back to
what to fix it you're a bad person
I accept okay and that's the one thing
too it's like my biggest problem with me
the captain may have got it back again
although we're all equal guys why that
walks around the hospital right oh shut
the [ __ ] up I love you guys man and
we're like you know media man yeah
[Music]